at what point do you think of it like
even though you love it and it's
something you did that was so great at
what point you're like all right like I
want to talk about other stuff I got
diarrhea I love talking about diarrhea
all day yeah yeah I was doing uh like a
charity event one time with Max Casella
who was on Doogie Howser and who's on
Sopranos and like somebody came up to
him and was like oh man I love Doogie
Howser and the guy's wife was like come
on like he doesn't want to hear that and
the guy was like that's why I have a
home go ahead like and that like kind of
Switched something for me or I was like
yeah that's that's the reason why like I
have you know like I'm not 40 and living
with my mom potentially like you know
what I mean it's so yeah I never I never
get sick of
not that I don't get sick of talking
about it but I never am like bothered to
talk about it yeah and you know a lot of
our podcasts not a lot of it but there's
always a segment that you know just
pokes fun at the fact of how little we
actually know about Sopranos yeah I've
never watched it like and she's never
seen all of it she's seen like half
right so they'll quiz us
um with fairly simple questions that we
usually get wrong people get so mad that
we don't know like so like really really
mad how could you not know the name of
the boat I didn't watch the show I don't
know they're like you were on the boat I
don't know I can't read the side of it
what do you want me to tell you what's
your memories of that show are so
obviously so different because you're on
it but like you like when you think of
the show you're thinking of the camera
looking at you and craft services and
all the stuff that was really kind of
wrapped around it as opposed to seeing
as a finished work so I kind of get why
you wouldn't know all the ins and outs
of it because why would you want to
watch yourself it's just uncomfortable
yeah I don't remember most things that
people ask me about which is also great
like when people want to talk to me
about the show it's a great thing to be
like I don't know you know like I can't
wait I genuinely don't know yeah we're
not brushing them off we even not have a
conversation about it episode 70 when he
said this what did he mean I'm like I
don't even know I could just say like I
don't know instead of having like
Michael Imperioli wrote for the show
everything so he has to sit there and
actually talk to people about like what
did this character mean by this and this
where I'm like dude this is on you like
um yeah I don't know [__] who's Tony
serico like oh my God you you know
exactly what he's like
yeah
he smells like the strongest cologne you
can ever you smelled like him for days
after you saw him he was the best the
type of guy who shook your hand in your
hand would smell like cologne or or you
know every once in a while like I would
always make sure that if I was wearing a
ring it was the right way because he
would squeeze your hands so tight like
every once in a while you know it just
gets you he so he had whenever we'd be
on like the red carpets for [__] he
would reach into his suit pocket and
pull out he had a mini bottle of
obsession and he would pour it in his
hand and he would put it on your face on
your neck and he'd be like here here
they love it they love it yeah oh my God
so you get in a car with him and just at
the whole car would just smell like
Obsession that's such a pleasant smell
too in high school my favorite cologne
was Obsession by Calvin Klein yeah
there's a lot of like memories that come
flooding back when you get that scent
yeah there is a there it's one thing to
be like welcoming it's another thing to
actually cologne people yeah
now put this on put this on yeah it's an
aggressive it is aggressive that only he
could get away with right right yeah
because he's doing it for you that's
right
we would like so they had like the the
Emmys and [__] you sit like you're in a
[__] Auditorium like you're at school
you know what I mean but then they had
the SAG Awards where you sit at like a
dinner table you're eating there's food
there's wine and I remember uh at like
the first one we ever went to he lit a
cigarette at the [__] Saddles man
yeah he lit a cigarette and like
security came over and was like what are
you doing he wasn't putting it out
either like he was like he's like yeah
I'll hold it down like I was holding it
under the table it was CR you're sitting
us like Richard Dreyfuss you know what I
mean people were looking at you like
this guy's [__] smoking but he was he
he did time like I know you know he's a
he was uh he was the real deal right
yeah yeah I do love people that smoke in
public in inappropriate places just
because it's become such a social faux
pas but the like we had when we had
Andrew Dice Clay in here he's the only
person that's come into the radio studio
and just started chain smoking and we're
like he can't he was like get me an
ashtray all right
2015 no one smokes indoors anymore they
have it for 15 years all the other shows
started complaining because the it's
going through the events yeah the ducks
go to all the other Studios they're like
why does it smell like cigarette smoke
in here but like what are you if you
want to tell them stop nobody
volunteered yeah yeah that's a very old
school attitude like dice used to smoke
in the airport it's a power move it is
yeah because you know you're not
supposed to he would smoke at an airport
and if they said something he would say
oh he got permission from the mayor
and people would just believe I'm gonna
use that yeah permission from the mayor
there's also something about deep down
just wanting to get kicked out of places
you know what I mean of being like
you're gonna kick me out great right
like you know it's [__] 6 a.m kick me
out kick me out you know yeah were you
guys ever afraid you weren't going to
get picked up like in between seasons
one and two maybe or did you know
immediately this is here for as long as
we want it yeah it was it was always
kind of that Vibe it was more of like
how much longer does David want to do
this to the point where he had a meeting
with all of us
um where we thought we were filming the
last season and brought us all in and
said I I'm gonna do eight more which is
when there was like the six oh yes yeah
whatever uh we were in the middle of
filming 6A and thought that that was
going to be it and he called us in and
said would you guys want to do more and
I think Rob I think you were the one
that was like you had me at hello like
no problem I don't think any of us are
gonna say no he came in like it was like
a real serious thing and he's like
listen I've been thinking about it you
know what you wanted it and I was like
dude you had like the second you walked
in the yeah we're all here like let's
let's [__] can you imagine if
someone's like uh you know yeah like if
one person was like you know it's been
fun but yeah you know Dave I think it's
time I think I think I do wish there was
one person who hadn't done the last
eight episodes because they thought it
had run its course yeah
they had another show that got canceled
after a season or something Tony cerrico
used to go up to writers and be like
yeah there's only one rule around here
like I I don't go like for their first
day
I don't know if David told you yet but
there's no part of the script where it's
even a question yeah of am I coming back
he wouldn't let them write him in as a
snitch that's one thing he wouldn't do
is somebody who had turned he said that
they would he wouldn't let them write
him I don't know that but that sounds
like something
that could have happened and there was
one scene where they had to mess up his
hair and it was like the biggest deal
like he was unhappy about it you could
not talk because there's like hair
people and sometimes when they're new
they didn't know that you're not
supposed to touch his hair and they
would come over to like that and he
would he did his own hair and he was the
biggest sweetheart ever but if he would
just if somebody touched his hair it was
like his his Masterpiece you know it was
probably Pine bearings remember that
whatever his hair was like all over the
place on the sides exactly and you guys
I didn't ask about the last episode all
the time so I only want to ask you when
you got the script did the script read
exactly as we saw it or was there
anything different or was it was it
Ambiguously it was in the script yeah or
they shoot it differently than the
script it made it
like well I wasn't I was there I wasn't
there the day that they were shooting
the inside of holsteins it was a whole
separate day that they shot all the
stuff with me in the parallel parking
but I don't I don't remember it saying
like cut to black or you know I think it
was more of just like a fade or how you
would normally end a scene that's how I
thought it was going to be because when
we watched it at a screening I remember
I was sitting next to Dominic chain AC
and we both turned around like what
happened we we thought the projector
went out like everybody else thought
their cable went out yeah right so I was
wondering if they had like a not a false
ending but did they reverse did you guys
get full scripts or only your parts we
got five scripts but they also put out
um different scriptures in case someone
found because like a lot of times it's
like oh you would leave your script and
a jacket and then the Wardrobe would
sell that jacket for like ten dollars to
Goodwill and somebody would grab it and
be like holy [__] this is the last scene
of the [__] yeah and besides I think
by the end like the sides were always
collected
um and then scripts were watermarked
we only got the pages we were
some or some there was it was getting
more lockdown by the end I was partying
so hard then man I had I don't I don't
know like I don't I remember
yeah it was it was a crazy you always
brought it to work though you never oh I
never never brought that side of your
life but I remember there was a time
where one time David also like took us
into a meeting and he was like I want to
take a year off like you remember and he
was I just want to take a year to do
that and like everybody was like okay
cool and then when he kind of got up and
left and everyone was like oh my God
like Edie was like what am I gonna do
should I do a play and Lorraine was like
what am I going to work on this and I
was like you guys are in [__] nuts
you're thinking about what you're gonna
work on we've got a year off and we know
we're coming back yeah like I was like
I'm [__] let's go let's go to the
let's go over to the bar like I'm like
hey I want to hang out with my friend
you know I just probably because
psychologically I missed all that [__]
you know I started in the business when
I was six years old right all I wanted
to do was hang out with my friends you
know yeah you have you already have
money you guaranteed more money coming
in that's right so you just got a year
to hang out yeah that's what I heard
anywhere everybody else heard so what
are you guys gonna work on the next year
which is like that's crazy absolutely
not that me and you Dave we're taking a
year off yeah yeah
would you ever get [__] up at work
like would you ever like uh whatever you
would do in the trailer so I had a uh
one of my buddies was like we became
such good friends with like the
everybody who worked on the crew and
everything and one of my buddies uh who
was a PA had a bottle of Jaeger in the
hair makeup trailer and it was like the
second we would rap it was just like
Bank bank but it was I never the only
time it really interfered with work was
on my 21st birthday when I went to Vegas
and I came back with no voice and they
were like yeah like I showed up to work
and I was like and they're like yeah we
have to film we have to like reschedule
this day and then um another time we
were filming in was that Long Island
when I got [__] trash Oh The Wedding
well yeah we filmed a wedding scene uh
it was whose wedding was it I think it
was like Vince kiratoso John
because there were hundreds of people
and it was like I mean and so when you
film scenes like that
it's all these little vignettes so
you're waiting around eight hours doing
nothing yeah so so these people come
over to us and like hey we have a bar up
the block when you guys are wrapped
we'll close it down and I was like okay
I don't have any lines I'm not in the
scene I'm like hey let's we'll all go
and everybody went to the bar after it
was just us and I got behind the bar and
I started making shots for and every
shot that I made for people I would take
a shot and then like I just got [__]
wasted and I remember
uh at like 9 00 a.m uh Jeff marchetti
coming into my hotel room and he's like
dude we're waiting for you on set but
he's like no one knows that you're not
there so Michael Imperioli was staying
in the room next to me and he's like um
and and I'm like I see him on set and
I'm like dude you don't wake me up to
leave with you I'm like you just leave
it out and he goes I came I tried to
wake you up and he goes you you looked
up in the bed with your eyes closed and
you pointed like you were clicking a
like the mute button on a remote and
he's like and you wouldn't get up you
just went back to sleep and out and I
was like oh my bad
that's not cool but luckily like they
were filming so much stuff that no one
knew I wasn't there yeah you know but
you got away with one yeah yeah but
otherwise I never even came close like
if I if I knew I had to work on like a
Thursday I wouldn't go out to drink on a
Saturday because I was like I know I
could drink for three days and it could
lead into [__] me even being a little
hungry because like I was fully aware
that I was working on a show where
everyone was better actors than me like
we were working with the best actors in
the world so I was like I can't be the
worst actor and then show up [__] up
like you know if you're the best actor
you could show up [__] up but if
you're the last guy on the list you
gotta be at least I'm sober yeah yeah
yeah yeah I know my lines dude like you
know that was that was what you know
because I thought I could bring was that
moment like a specific moment where
you're like oh okay I can't even attempt
Fate on this like I I can't get caught
not being at a scene like I got one free
no because that was later in the show
you know I knew I knew you know I
started partying when I was like 12 13.
so I knew right in the beginning like
yeah I was like yo I can't I can't ever
let this interfere with this like
because this is you know I grew up in
income housing you know what I mean so
my family was like yo this is the ticket
like where you're you're getting out
like you know and I was like okay I just
I knew you know I couldn't
I couldn't let it get in the way and
also I was like I get to go to all these
dope parties because I'm on the show
right so if the show goes away the dope
parties go I guess I'll come to the
party right right yeah exactly so it was
you know you don't want to be written
off like you know what I mean you don't
want to be or have less because they're
like he's not reliable so we'll have him
kind of in the background when you could
actually be doing something yeah yeah
and it's also just respect I mean
I mean we're he's never lost on us ever
what we were of and
fun as it was as great of a time as it
was like that the reason why he was so
successful is people work so hard on
that show and for that show I mean
actors crew everyone was there anybody
you never had a scene with that you
wanted to
Lorraine like nobody had a scene with
her really except for Jim so we would it
was like we were on a show with her for
10 years and never worked it was a very
weird thing where it was like do we have
this family and she's a member of the
family but nobody ever sees her in that
it was it was weird we always wanted and
we were close with her because she was
like you know she was so
great and she
and shoving and especially to Rob and I
because she had kids our age
um so yeah Lorraine was one and then
when we could have like really cool
guest stars like John Favreau like I was
like you know we would be he came to the
table read but I was like oh man it
would be so cool to be in a scene with
him yeah how long does it take your
eyebrows to grow back in after they
shave them so they actually did uh they
got the guy the makeup guy from Dick
Tracy wow who like apparently was like
an oscar-winning like because
like obviously I didn't want to shave my
eyebrows but they were all so worried of
like well how does it grow back the next
episode like because we have to film The
Next Episode in seven days my eyebrows
are gonna be back and so how are they
gonna do that in this so I would I'd
show up to work at you know if we had to
start filming at 7am I would show up at
5am so I'd wake up at you know 3 30 a.m
I would get there fall asleep in the
chair and I'd wake up with no eyebrows
so it's like as soon and you wake up in
the hair makeup trailer where it's all
mirrors and it was like the second you'd
wake up and you know you don't know
where you are for a second then you have
no eyebrows I remember like multiple
days waking up I was like this is
[__] bizarre yeah it looks weird
right yeah how long do they take to grow
back I don't know but I'm sure that it's
a while yeah if you're filming another
scene in seven days and it's supposed to
be like time has passed yeah it's not
gonna and also sometimes you would have
to film the scene with no eyebrows then
two days later film a scene from earlier
that episode
how are you then uh there's just no but
I've heard movie Magic what they were
saying was everyone's different they
were like some people your eyebrows go
back like it's nothing like some people
they just don't grow back like some
people it takes forever oh yeah what do
we got three to four months four months
that's a long time to have no eyebrows
yeah that would have been a tremendous
hit yeah
yeah can you imagine they didn't grow
back and like you have to do the finals
it's hard to watch someone for that long
if I'm sitting here right now still just
don't know yeah I know it's stupid yeah
yeah and also just I always knew like
I'm not an actor you know what I mean
like I knew it wasn't fit like when I
did Sopranos I was like I love this and
so I thought I loved acting and then
when I tried to do acting after it I was
like oh this isn't that like this and
that's what everybody on soprano said
like they had been acting for 10 20 30
years so they were like you don't know
how lucky you are and I was 12 I was
like oh everyone doesn't get on a hit
show like yeah you know so I I really
didn't know and then afterwards you go
and you do stuff and like people stay in
their campers and they show up and they
do their lines and they go back and
that's where we were like we were
waiting for them to yell cut so we could
like all sit at the bar together and
talk and laugh and do stupid [__] and it
was just you know we couldn't wait like
nobody wanted to go to the Emmys but
everybody wanted to hang out and and you
know it was like oh who's on my flight
and you'd get so excited by like who's
on my flight because I don't get to do
scenes with this person but now we're
going to be on the same flight for six
hours right why do you think that was
like what what was it about that show
because you hear like nightmare stories
about other shows where the co-stars
don't get along nobody wants to be there
so it was the fact that we were in New
York it was the fact that nobody was
very famous when we started and legit
that if you were an [__] David Chase
could write you off and he would like he
would just he could kill you like you
always knew that in your head like I
could look at the last page tomorrow and
I could die like it's not like I'm on ER
or something where it's like hey where
where did the kid go like I could die no
no competition there was no ego there
was I remember there was one guest star
one time and it literally like sent a
ripple through the entire
Sopranos like silver cup Universe
because it was like oh there's like a
diva on the set right now like it was it
it set everybody off so badly because we
had not experienced that the entire time
were they only on one episode or was it
a few episodes one episode
it like shook everybody to the core
where I almost and veterans that are
working on the show like oh no I forgot
yeah that people can be like this were
you guys protective of like the
environment like if you started to sense
that was happening were you like no no
we got to shut this down because I mean
Jim was yeah we didn't even have to be
because it would already happen and
that's the thing like it starts at the
top where like if you see the way Jim is
acting somebody else can't come and be
like a prima donna when he doesn't care
like yeah you go to like LA and [__] and
people will fight over whose camper is
part closer to the set where they're
like Jim would be like yo like I you
know I have a thing about [__] in
public and Jim would be like I'm [__] in
my camper like you know what I mean yeah
where he's just like whatever whatever
happens
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no you don't understand what I mean
by camper and it was also weird
sometimes when somebody would come on
and be like excited to be on the show
because we were like you know you you're
on day 900 of working with the same
people showing up to the same spot and
you're like yeah we're doing our thing
and then somebody would come on and be
like oh my God like he he's he's wearing
the robe and what and you're like what
like you know like you don't you don't
realize that like oh yeah this is
[__] iconic there was somebody that
came on once and like was supposed to
have a part for a while and was not
professional did not know their lines
was not bringing it and David was like
recast
they just recasted them right there yep
that's humiliating especially on a show
like that yeah and this was established
person yeah and he probably told for
yeah um
shot the pilot didn't you shoot that in
97 or 98 like wasn't it a couple of
years before a full year between the
pilot and filming the second episode did
you know it was gonna happen or were you
like we have no idea if we're getting
picked up or not I feel like I remember
we shot the pilot in the summer like
July August
I remember going to a screening in La
for it in November and maybe around like
January february-ish we heard we were
going to be picked up I mean HBO was
like a new network per se like as far as
original programming it used to be the
movie channel so because I remember
telling people I'm going to be on a show
on HBO and they were like the movie
channel I'm like yeah because what did
they have at that point
yeah like like if you had HBO you loved
the Larry Sanders show but you weren't
like oh I'm getting HBO because the
Larry Sanders show was on it you know
where I think Sex and the City and
Sopranos definitely were like oh I have
to get HBO now it's also one of those
shows by the way that like you can go
back and watch that anytime that show
holds up so well Larry Sanders
incredible yeah it's also going to be
nice to have such faith in the material
like when you want to like if you go on
a set now and do something I'm sure it's
good but like some of the material is
like oh like when you've when you've
been on a masterpiece to go from there
to something else has got to be
difficult to just respect what they're
asking you to say yeah I'm sure that's
like a lot of what you were talking
about that you felt Rob of like going
into something else because yeah it was
just it was is just all there and it's
just you know it was lightning in a
bottle I mean it's like we were all
perfect for the roles that we were
playing at that time in our lives this
Synergy like the chemistry the respect I
think just like all of it just it just
was one of those special moments in time
when I so I had been auditioning for
like six years getting like commercials
and I did a couple of things I did like
SNL and like this just random [__] and
then I remember like my manager being
like you got a TV show like this is
[__] you got a TV show and I remember
telling my family and I was like oh my
God this is it like this is the thing
we're [__] we're get we're getting out
and then uh when we're recording the
pilot I said that to Tony sarigo I'm
like dude my family's pumped we're all
getting [__] cars and we're getting
Antonio was like Tony strico was like
you know how many of these we do he goes
you're lucky if we ever see each other
again and I was like it was like a punch
to like I was like oh no I was like we
all thought so then I have to go back to
my family as a 12 year old and be like
yeah this isn't it like they do these
things all the time you know what I mean
and it was like oh okay like yeah we
didn't know we thought you were just now
like we thought you'd get a TV show and
that's it that's it you know